as Prince area continues his goodbye
tour plans for his new life in North
America they've hit a roadblock the
Canadian government says it will not pay
the security cost for Harry and Meagan
Markel after they officially stepped
down from their royal duties that news
comes as the Prince met with John
Bongiovi about a cause close to Harry's
heart his Invictus games Foundation
it supports injured wounded or sick
members of the military Ian Lee reports
from London rock royalty meets British
royalty ax Abbey Road Studios in London
where legendary bands like The Beatles
and Pink Floyd once recorded but the duo
is striking a new tune with the Invictus
choir these service members are singing
a remix of unbroken Bon Jovi's song
about the struggles faced after leaving
the military Bon Jovi song unbroken is a
powerful song but it probably for you
guys as personal as well
absolutely absolutely there's a few
lines in the song I was involved in on
ie D 30 years ago and I've still got the
ringing in my ears
[Music]
the last lines for me where he says when
you asked me if it was worth it and you
say yeah and I'd do it all again and
actually that's quite hard to say out
loud some deal asked me was it worth it
said that you hope that the soldiers
would feel pride from this song and
working with them do you feel like you
accomplished that I think so yeah you
know when when I wrote it
it had to be honest I couldn't sugarcoat
anything if I was gonna ask them to sing
it this performance is the swan song of
sorts for Prince Harry as a senior royal
he surrenders his duties next month and
while he'll say goodbye to Britain and
hello to North America he won't be
giving up the Invictus foundation how
important is Prince Harry to all of this
inspiration he's an ex-soldier yeah and
he still understands as for Megan she
will join Harry for one of her final
engagements as a senior royal next week
that will also highlight members of the
military and Gayle I just spoke to Bon
Jovi and he made sure to give a special
shout out to you all things Jon Bon Jovi
at this table he's been here thanks a
lot Ian Lee we say a shout out right
back to you Jon thanks a lot